well, the need today, the need for troops
today is such that yes, there is a problem with
ammunition, especially in the post-Soviet
space, it is 122 millimeter, 152 millimeter, etc.
Today, these problems are
present today in all parts of the front, you do not
understand what to say, that help is
not coming, I would not say such a thing  Yes, it is
coming, it is coming, but in the
amounts that we have today, we have
this need, it does not satisfy us completely,
therefore we are directly
redistributing these funds and, accordingly,
replanning there and those tasks that we
planned to do and more on less,
so to speak  Yemini, because we need to
secure the enemy today, well, I won't
say that he stopped us, but in
some areas of the front,
we went on the defensive.
therefore, somewhere we
pass and somewhere we pass, we
continue our respective offensive
actions
by maneuvering by fire by
moving forward, but we do not intend to do so.
We are on the front line. Yes,
he is not so fresh today,
he is not so fresh with us, as it were, he is rested, but taking into
account today's
situation, the question is being worked out in each brigade.  the
unit
constantly does not rest, well, it understood that
fighting in winter is more difficult than in summer and it
will be more difficult for us and the Russian
occupiers, this is also the temperature regime, this is also
bad weather and snow and the absence of
leaves, so to speak, which directly has
some means of
camouflage and some other factors that
require adjustment Well  and they accordingly
correct our actions, although we
have many years of experience in conducting
military operations in winter conditions. All the same,
people need to be trained not directly.
There is nothing worse than poorly trained
trained people on the battlefield.
Logistics are complicated. Fortifications are equipped. Well, the
evacuation itself is limited directly.  the possibility of
moving equipment and personnel,
and with the presence of the F16, it will be completely
that. In my opinion, as a general
commander of an infantry officer, the F16 is
something between a Zaporozhian and
a Mercedes, so everyone hopes